[Music]
season two of star trek picard all led
up to this finale with the deaths of
several characters surprise new threats
and allies and a ton of reveals that
raise more questions than the answer oh
and wesley crusher's back too caution
more spoilers ahead
in the previous episode hide and seek
the departing jarate board queen hybrid
had a final message for picard as she
left earth
to restore the timeline one rene picard
must live while another must die
to succeed there must be two renees
one who lives
and another who dies
as the season finale begins picard is
mystified by the message's meaning but
he soon has a light bulb moment
and tallinn gives him a knowing glance
the group splits up with picard
surprising tallinn by entering her
transport window and going with her to
the europa mission launch site there
they must ensure that renee picard
boards the flight and takes off
successfully at the launch site we soon
learned just what the gerardi queen
meant but not before tallinn visits
renee and earns her trust tollen
explains how she has watched over renee
all her life and she must trust her now
it is critical that she gets on the
europa flight but her life may be in
danger and tolen is right because adam
soon is there to assassinate renee as he
bumps into her in a hallway soom strikes
using a neurotoxin laced on his palm and
rene collapses deep in shock we soon
learn however that this is not rene at
all tallen has used her holographic
disguise to impersonate picard's
ancestor allowing the rio renee to board
the shuttle one renee dies the other
lives discovering tall and near death
picard cradles her as the shuttle takes
off as they fulfill their mission to
ensure the future
killing renee wasn't soon's only planned
to sabotage the launch of the europa
mission
while picard and tallinn had gone to the
launch site to saber seven of nine rafi
and rios headed to sung's lab and
discovered his last desperate failsafe a
series of drones designed to destroy the
shuttle even if it was in flight while
they are unable to stop the drones from
launching ravi works to take manual
control over them and abort their deadly
mission it's a nail-biting sequence as
the drones take off one by one but in
the end rafi manages to get control of
one of them while rios uses his piloting
skill to destroy them all battalion
having thwarted his assassination
attempt of renee and rios destroying the
drones soon has failed and europa
successfully takes off returning to his
lab soon watches news reports of renee
picard aboard the shuttle on its way to
europa but as he wallows in frustration
he is shocked to see his computer
terminals buzzed to life as data begins
to be deleted a system-wide purge of all
of soon's research wipes out any hope
that he'll be able to revive his eugenic
research remotely his daughter corey has
found a way to prevent him from
continuing his horrific genetic
experiments
but just as all hope seems lost soon
pulls out a paper file a folder with a
sinister title project khan it would
seem he has some work ahead of him
perhaps to be fulfilled by his
descendant eric soon seen on star trek
enterprise set a hundred years later
perhaps the biggest surprise of the
finale if not the entire season is a
shocking cameo from will wheaton
reprising his role as wesley crusher it
all happens after corey has remotely
destroyed her father's research she
receives a mysterious invitation to a
los angeles address via her tablet
computer to learn more about what's next
for her she arrives and meets a strange
man we recognize as wesley crusher who
tells her that he is a being that
travels all of time and space and he
wants her to join him this follows the
events of the next generation season 7
episode journey's end in which wesley
left the enterprise with an enigmatic
being called the traveler after
exhibiting incredible nearly godlike
powers
in the picard finale wesley finally
clears up two long unresolved pieces of
franchise lore tying together the
traveler from tng and the character of
gary seven from the original series
[Music]
that's a lot you have no idea
it seems that the traveler and those
like him a group that now includes
wesley have access to all time and space
and have tasked themselves with ensuring
the sanctity and balance of the universe
it is these travelers that recruited
people like talin and gary seven to
watch historical events to ensure their
proper outcome he refers to himself as
watching all of time meaning the
travelers are the so-called watchers
that were referenced by gaianin earlier
in the season
ultimately corey leaves with wesley
presumably to become a new supervisor or
watcher with a new mission to keep tabs
on the fate of the universe
big job
tell me about it
while the mission to save history in the
21st century and geranti's merging with
the board queen were exciting elements
of season 2 the real adventure was in
picard facing up to a dark moment in his
past the death of his mother yvette when
he was a child in the final stretch of
the season we saw how picard's mother
experienced severe mental illness and
one fateful evening her husband locked
her in her room to keep her safe
but the young and naive jean-luc
responding to his mother's desperate
prize for help used an old skeleton key
to let her out after which she ended her
own life picard had felt responsible for
her death ever since and in the climax
of the finale picard in the 21st century
finds the skeleton key and places it in
the same spot where he found it as a
child allowing the future to fulfill
itself even though it means the death of
his mother q later points out that he
could have taken it hidden it and
changed history but here picard is
choosing to be the man that his mother's
death helped him become a lesson that
trek fans will recall he learned from q
back in the next generation episode
tapestry
the time travel story of season 2 of
course was kicked off with the arrival
of q who altered history and changed the
timeline forcing picard to travel back
in time and fix all of history we
learned that this final test was
instigated because q was slowly dying a
shocking twist for a self-described
immortal being q forced picard not just
to save the future but to confront his
past and forgive himself for the death
of his mother to seek absolution and
learn that the fate of others isn't
always his responsibility this turned
out to be a central theme of the season
mirrored by rafi and the death of elenor
after history has been set right picard
meets with q one final time he tells
picard that the legendary starfleet
officer has never allowed himself to
truly love another person and now
perhaps he will
perhaps he will now be worthy enough for
someone else to choose
and maybe this time you will even give
him the chance to be loved
hugh wants picard to be happy and
fulfilled after he's gone and he
explains why the card matters to him
even gods have favorites
and you've always been one of mine
hugh then says he doesn't want to die
alone and he has chosen one last visit
to be with his friend picard he wanted
to impart one final lesson to set his
heart free and to leave him unshackled
from the past in a touching final moment
picard hugs q before he moves on
[Music]
farewell
it's time for me to go
the picard season 2 finale moves at warp
speed wrapping up every character's
journey and tying off every loose plot
thread after q and picard speak one
final time q reveals that he's going to
use the last of his powers to send
picard and his friends back home to the
25th century but they're not all going
back rios announces that he intends to
stay behind saying he never really felt
at home in the future and the 21st
century is where he belongs though
ricard is concerned he ultimately
supports his friend in his decision to
build a life in 2024 later when picard
gets home to the 21st century gainen
tells him about what happened to rios
after they left he and teresa started a
medical movement together called the
mariposas
teresa's son ricardo grew up to become a
leader who helped develop new
technologies that cleaned the oceans and
healed the sky
over the years the three became friends
with gainen and she had always kept a
photo of them in her bar that she was
surprised picard had never noticed but
that's not the only twist with rios left
behind hugh says he has energy left for
one more surprise and we get it when
picard rafi and seven return to the
bridge of the stargazer rafi sends a
message to the uss excelsior and it is
cadet elenor who responds resurrected by
q with his dying breath rafi and eleanor
are finally reunited
the first plot line to begin the season
saw admiral picard brought back into
service to respond to a mysterious alien
signal that was calling his name a fleet
of federation starships arrived at the
scene of a massive anomaly where a
strange borg vessel emerged with a
request to join the united federation of
planets before picard could decide how
to respond a new kind of board queen
materialized on the bridge and attempted
to take control of the ship but just as
picard ordered the stargazer to
self-destruct he was hurtled into an
alternate reality by q now back in the
present and in the proper reality we
learned the truth about this new board
they are led by the dratty hybrid queen
created in 2024 and she has spent 400
years forming a new better board
collective they've come for picard's
help because a dangerous threat has
emerged one that can only be stopped by
the combined efforts of the borg and the
federation fleet
gerani takes control of the fleet and
together they avert a catastrophe that
would have killed billions but in the
wake of their victory a new danger
emerges the anomaly gives birth to a
strange trans-warp conduit but its
purpose and who created it remains a
mystery in her parting words to picard
gerardi asks for provisional federation
membership so they can monitor this new
threat perhaps laying the groundwork for
the third and final season of picard
throughout the second season of picard
we follow the fate to picard's ancestor
renee an astronaut on the verge of an
important space flight that is key to
earth's history in the future while
picard has stated in earlier episodes
that historical records from the 21st
century were spotty and nobody quite
knows why the europa mission was so
important it became clear that without
it earth would become a totalitarian
nightmare in the finale we get some
answers as to why and the importance
renee picard's mission had on the fate
of planet earth on her mission to europa
gaiman reveals that picard's ancestor
renee would help discover a unique alien
organism that would prove instrumental
to solving earth's problems
picard learns many lessons in season two
of the series mostly thanks to his old
nemesis q and finally accepting that his
mother's death was not his fault he has
found absolution within himself the one
thing that has been keeping him from
getting close to people in his life it
explains why he so often kept his
distance from both friends and lovers
never pursuing a serious romance whether
it was with dr crusher lieutenant darren
or the rabble-rousing relic hunter bosch
in the premiere picard and lloris may
clear a mutual romantic interest
unfortunately picard wasn't ready and
kept his distance far from tallinn's
heart but now in the finale having
accepted himself as he is thanks to his
adventure in time and worked through his
past trauma he returns to the 25th
century a renewed man ready to love he
meets with loris who is preparing to
leave picard's vineyard he stops her
asking her in his own way for a second
chance it remains to be seen where this
relationship will go but after all these
years it appears that jean-luc picard is
finally ready to fully embrace loving
another as the episode closes we see
picard and lars holding hands embarking
on a new romantic journey together
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]